un autre panel ce soir sébastien mauvais
et madeleine blé mort et bonsoir à vous
deux bons sauts j'ai bon commençons cbc
par ce couvre-feu ça commence demain 20
heures et on se demandait le il est où
le décret il vient de sortir il est où
il vient d'être publié puis je vous
avoue que c'est un langage plutôt légal
aux légalistes que c'est difficile d'y
voir devant les subtilités enfer je
comprends que essentiellement après une
lecture en diagonale
on nous rappelle donc les mesures qui
sont et qui sont appliquées pour les
commerces
on nous parle aussi de ski du couvre feu
donc entre 20h et 5h personne a le droit
d'être à l'extérieur on précise qu on a
droit d'être sur son terrain par exemple
par contre on est on est confiné donc à
notre maison il y à des exceptions
évidemment qui ont été annoncées par le
gouvernement donc celle égalise d'une
certaine façon se décrit ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est une démarche légale
pour donner les pouvoirs aux policiers
de faire ce qu'ils ont à faire
en prévision du couvre-feu d'ailleurs on
a appris en fin d'après midi et c'est
geneviève guilbault qui l'a twitté que
les policiers seront très présents il
est même question qu'ils fassent
fonctionner leur gyrophare dans les rues
de leur municipalité pour indiquer que
le couvre-feu est en vigueur et on
recevra en principe aussi une alerte sur
notre téléphone et sur notre téléviseur
alors on veut personnes soit plupart
sont prises et que ça soit clair en fait
parce que c'est très symbolique aussi en
comprend le csu plus de londres et
parfois de la communication contre 11,7
soit de couvre-feu parce que quand même
beaucoup d'exceptions et beaucoup de
gens qui vont pouvoir être dehors après
20 heures
en vertu de ces exceptions près
rappelez-vous ce qu'on vous disait ce
qu'on dit au début de la semaine en 10e
le gouvernement veut frapper
l'imaginaire le gouvernement veut donner
un traitement choc un électrochoc bassin
c'est ce qui est un peu comme dans ses
pieds en effet il y en a qui pensent que
c'est beaucoup à voir avec les
communications l opération de relations
publiques beaucoup plus qu'avec la
science qui appuie une mesure qui va
freiner la coved horacio arruda l'a dit
en conférence de presse il n'y a pas
d'étude scientifique empirique qui
permet de dire que le couvre-feu va
réduire là
la propagation de la maladie il a parlé
d'un panier de mesures qui allaient
réussir peut-être à le faire mais donc
il fallait d'une certaine façon c'est la
conclusion à laquelle on en est venu aux
gouvernements frappé l'imaginaire des
québécois
oui sauf que c'est vraiment une grosse
cartouche quand même parce que si ça n'a
pas l'effet escompté
est ce qu'il reste encore des munitions
il reste le confinement total comme on a
presque connue au printemps dernier où
peu à peu près à peu de choses près donc
en effet moi je vous dis j'ai comme
l'impression que c'est l'avant dernière
étape après le couvre-feu qu'est ce qui
reste
il reste le confinement total tout le
monde chez soi et seulement les
épiceries ouvertes des pharmacies puis
on fait pas grand chose de plus
ce qui a marqué la semaine aussi c'est
cette espèce de bisbee là autour d'eux
est ce que les provinces font bien leurs
devoirs avec leurs vaccins ou pas est-ce
que justin trudeau fournit bien ce qui
doit fournir aussi pour les vaccins ça
vraiment été sont d'accrochages à
répétition je dirais cette semaine
madeleine
on a l'impression que justin trudeau et
en rattrapage aujourd'hui on va faire
rejoindre et extraire téléspectateurs
c'était le premier extrait au début de
la semaine ce qui le disons province etc
suivi de ce qu'ils y aujourd'hui on est
tous ensemble on veut pas voir des
vaccins dans des congélateurs on peut
les voir dans les bras des canadiens
vulnérables on est là pour continuer
d'aider les provinces qui accélère le
pas d'une façon assez impressionnante au
au cours de sept semaines et des
semaines à venir
bon ben alors qu'il était dans les
compliments aux provinces aujourd'huile
oui absolument dans la coopération dans
la politique de la main tendue pour dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aider
on n'était plus du tout dans les
reproches dans l'impatience pour dire on
veut pas voir de doses dans des
congélateurs sa malle patience et
commentaires là auprès des provinces et
ottawa et les provinces sont condamnés à
valser ensemble dans ce dossier là parce
qu'ottawa s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement et les provinces
hawks qui s'occupe de la vaccination
on avait l'impression au milieu de la
semaine que ottawa comme les provinces
arrivait sur le plancher de danse avec
des gants de boxe s'est passé n'est pas
très élégant je vous dirai ce qui se
passait alors que les canadiens ont
probablement pas de patience pour ce
genre de guéguerres politiques là auquel
on est habitué d'habitude mais là on
n'est pas dans la même dynamique on est
dans l'opération vaccination ça
représente la lumière au bout du tunnel
on parlait de l'électrochoc du
couvre-feu
peut-être que la mesure vaut mieux
passer si on a l'impression que tout ça
ça achève qu'on va justement pouvoir
s'en sortir et le les vaccins c'est le
billet pour pouvoir sortir de cette
pandémie là donc
ottawa les provinces je vous ayez on de
part et d'autre qu'elle me le temps
parce que une rencontre des premiers
ministres des provinces et de justin
trudeau hier soir et il n'y a pas eu de
bisbee sur la ligne on essayait je pense
un petit peu de réduire la température
mais il ya quand même un enjeu en termes
d'approvisionnement parce que le canada
a passé des commandes auprès des
différentes compagnies là il y en a deux
qui sont autorisés ce qu'on apprenait
aujourd'hui c'est que on va avoir reçu
d'ici la fin mars
6 millions de vaccins au total sur le
territoire canadien
mais on est quand même beaucoup plus
nombreux que ça et tout le monde
voudrait que ça s'accélère on avait
l'impression d'une certaine lenteur dans
les dernières semaines le 6 millions de
doses
on est je vous dirai dans les mêmes
chiffres qu'on connaissait déjà depuis
quelques semaines mais ce qu'on a appris
aussi aujourd'hui c'est que la ministre
de l'approvisionnement anita annales dit
toutes les options sont sur la table
pourrait essayer d'accélérer
l'approvisionnement des vaccins est ce
que ça veut dire accélérer ses 6
millions de doses là où à accélérer
celles qui vont suivre
mais lorsqu'on a posé la question à la
ministre est ce que ça veut dire par
exemple vouloir payer davantage pour
avoir les vaccins plus vite
donc elle ne pas exclu cette possibilité
là je vous dirai quand on éteint à un
déficit de 3 180 milliards de dollars
ce serait peut-être pas une bonne idée
de commencer à être chiche sur cette
question là encore une fois parce que ce
sont les vaccins qui vont nous permettre
de faire la reprise économique de
rouvrir les entreprises aux canadiens de
retourner au travail
donc si on paye quelques centaines de
millions de dollars je lance un chiffre
parce qu on en a pas eu de chiffres mais
on voulait surtout pas dire on allait
être on à les calculer nos sources sur
cette question là précisément être
économe en sur une question sentais
comme ça alors que copé visite mais
c'est bassiste qui est quand même
étonnant c'est que celui qui comme en
charge de l'opération vaccins au québec
ne qui n'est pas mal
en général c'est un civil on a appris
finalement que lui avait pas été au
courant qui a vu un changement de plan
complet distribuer plus largement la
première dont cesse et de réserver dans
un congélateur la deuxième dose précise
l'occitane plus grand nombre parfois on
dirait qu'il ya encore des problèmes de
communication sur le plan et c'est au
québec
oui pis monsieur pâris et c'est son nom
là a pris le 31 décembre que le
gouvernement du québec changé de vision
là dedans il ya eu de la confusion aussi
dans les rapports avec chargeur
le gouvernement dit enfin je nous
recommandait de garder la deuxième dose
de côté c'est la raison pour laquelle on
n'a pas injecté deux premières doses à
plus de monde n'est pas heureux a dit
ben c'est pas vraiment une
recommandation mais c'est peut-être ce
qui serait idéal mais vous pouvez faire
ce que vous voulez avec vos deux boeufs
il ya eu des problèmes de communication
avec trois heures et à l'intérieur même
du gouvernement ait eu des problèmes de
communication aussi avant que le
gouvernement décide finalement de
changer sa stratégie puis de 10,2 de
prendre des doses étaient réservées pour
la deuxième dose est dans de les
transformer en première dose pour
augmenter l'immunité du plus grand
nombre de personnes relativement
rapidement mais le problème c'est que
les doses arrive pas et ça c'est le
travail du gouvernement du canada
d'amener des dojos comme au canada de
les distribuer dans les provinces le
gouvernement du québec dit qu'il est
prêt il est capable de vacciner 250
personnes par semaine mais il ya juste
pas assez douces pour la saison on en a
reçu un peu plus de 100000 je pense ou
dernier il faudrait peut être allongée
de l'argent un petit peu plus dans un
côté amenant des dombes israël a fait ça
je crois qu'ils ont payé je crois que la
dose vaut 15 20 dollars la dose
ils ont payé autour de 50 60 $ là donc
ils ont réussi à en avoir plus plus
rapidement qu'ils ont baissé de secret
d'état saint madeleine on veut pas trop
nous en donner sur le prix tout seul
mais en fait parce que ça nuit à la
négociation avec les autres compagnies
pharmaceutiques par la suite on a sept
candidats vaccins avec lesquels on a des
ententes l'offre avec les compagnies
comme à cette section donne trop
d'informations on risque de payer plus
cher je vous dirai pour toutes les
autres aussi il ya cette logique là mais
souvenez vous lors de la première vague
à quel point on était dans un far west
sur la question des masques de
l'équipement de protection médicale on
nous disait avec les vaccins on a voulu
faire autrement
négocier rapidement mais moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est encore en train
de vivre un petit peu cette chasse
vaccin tout le monde veut avoir les
mêmes doses en même temps et là il
semble qu'il commence à y avoir un peu
de surenchère pétition avec la planète
c'est sont dans les faits il reste une
minute trente sébastien je vous amène
sur la question je viens de faire une
entrevue avec le ministre de l'éducation
m roberge
on a abordé la question très épineuse
aérosols ya une sortie de 300 experts
qui disent il faut mettre les espèces de
filtreurs d'air dans les classes mais
sur berge arrive avec monsieur merci de
la santé publique en ce sens d'une
mauvaise idée on veut nuire plutôt qu'un
disque on a réglé le problème ou paul y
est je ne sais pas par quel bout le
prendre à moi et je mets les missions
jusqu'à un certain point faut se fier à
la science le gouvernement en main une
étude qui dit les aérosols saisir les
ventilations dans les écoles c'est pas
nécessairement un problème on va quand
même continuer les études et on va voir
mais quand même une reconnaissance qui
peut y avoir un problème avec les
aérosols donc la solution c'est de bien
ventiler les écoles elissalde de classe
jusqu'à preuve du contraire elles sont
bien ventilé on verra quand la recension
des 3000 cas cela aura été fait mais
peut-être que déjà à ce moment là quand
on aura ces résultats là tout le monde
au québec corps avaient été vaccinées
bon mais pensez vous que le débat
d'experts se faisait son affaire
l'expert pensez vous que c'est terminé
sa non moi je pense que c'est comme les
avocats vous en mettez doses en une
salle puis vous aurez 12 réponses
différentes à la même question sont
bonnes réponses assez basses et
madeleine s'est passé merci beaucoup 25
semaines pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
m